alright so we just got used that six
officers in Baltimore are gonna go on
trial in the murder of Freddie gray
obviously the last week or so in
Baltimore has been completely bananas
between protests and riots it seems in
this case that maybe the system is going
to do the right thing right I mean we
don't know exactly what all the facts
are of course people on both sides are
saying this or that happened but finally
the system is at least getting this
thing to trial that is progress you know
the last few of these couldn't even get
out of the grand jury right they didn't
even get to trial so we don't know if
these people are going to be convicted
maybe some of them will maybe some of
them won't maybe they'll be found for
negligence hopefully the whatever the
truth is that's what we all want to
happen here but at least the steps to
justice are lined up here for something
good to happen so when I say is I good I
mean that some sort of justice is too
late for justice for Freddie but at
least we could have justice so that
people going forward will be able to
feel that the system is not working
against them and that's that's the hope
all right we'll see